that fist was right in my face and went
bam
and it was like white for a second and
then
i looked at her and then another fist
bam right in my face she sucked you she
sucked me right in my face right outside
and then i looked at i was like what
stop hitting me
and i had to grab her hand finally i'm
holding both her wrists
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast we have one of our favorite
guests ed
park vp here today what's up cheers
cheers
uh you guys want to hear something
[ __ ] funny so
so uh in this office space that i rent
out
the door that i have actually
automatically locks
i have locked myself out of this office
maybe about three times now
twice with me twice with ed now so
we [ __ ] locked ourselves out of this
office and this happens every time like
i'm in mid-conversation i'm not really
thinking
we both locked both of our car keys
inside so even if we wanted to leave we
cut it
and so i've done this multiple times and
the last time i did this i had to leave
my car here
um in the office area for [ __ ] three
days and hope my car didn't get stolen
yeah
which it didn't and then for some reason
today i was like
why don't i just call a [ __ ]
locksmith yeah
the three times i've no i never thought
about calling a lot today yeah
locksmith came and saved the day
meanwhile we were waiting out for like
40 minutes
listening to uh clubhouse yeah clubhouse
i gotta let you go okay we gotta talk
about this okay okay
so if you guys don't know what clubhouse
is clubhouse is like this hot new
i wouldn't know if you even call it
social media thing right so the way
clubhouse was sold to me
was that it's a great way for people to
network to either gain knowledge get
jobs or whatever meet people who are
important right
so i went on a clubhouse once and the
one experience that i had it was great i
was it was just a conversation with my
buddy frieza
this other guy named sam i believe um uh
danny chung and my buddy khalif and we
were just you know chopping it up having
great conversation it was like honestly
having a podcast with like five people
yeah um and clubhouse you are invited
through invites only so they kind of
make it exclusive i think that's like a
really good marketing tool for it right
um so i happen to hop on to
a a clubhouse chat room with a couple of
people like this
first of all it's just if you guys know
who king loses king loss is like one of
my favorite rappers
on clubhouse the topic was about how
just because something is written long
ago
it doesn't mean that the information is
true the reason why that came up is
because
king lost was talking about what he
reads he only reads stuff that are
hieroglyphs
because we we tuned in he goes i don't
read
i don't read and if you're like wait
wait wait what do you mean you don't
read he's like
i don't read
he words i don't read anything that's
man-made
and then as he say he goes i don't [ __ ]
with anything that's man-made as he's on
an
app on a phone that's paid broadcasting
your voice to
millions of people on something that's
man-made
yeah and i'm like yo is this guy a troll
because i know he does trolls [ __ ] but
he was actually serious in this
conversation
and so to that somebody said that
empirical he goes well you can't say
that just because you read something
from long ago
that that's considered empirical
evidence just because it's dated
right something from the past doesn't
mean that it shows
truth in the future right there is there
is no direct correlation that she was
completely right
which is just common sense right and
he's arguing against it by the way
and she goes this is what she said she
goes empirical evidence requires
information to be concrete and to that
somebody said i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
in anger hieroglyphs are literally
written in stone
so it's concrete
i mean you're it's like technically
right
else says right after that
yo celebrities are some of the dumbest
[ __ ] people on earth dude
this is what i'm talking about just
because you have a platform
doesn't mean you should speak these are
all lessons that we can learn in
critical thinking
and deconstruction of confirmation bias
it's just well this is what
you know and people argue about the
stuff too they go well you know well you
think it's because he's a rapper he's
not smart no i don't think he's smart
because he says stupid [ __ ]
the man literally said that because he
reads things that's
that predicts something that's written
on paper that
what he read back in the day is more
truthful than stuff that is written on
more
current type of um stationary yeah
that that is the requirement for
something that's truthful
nothing past papyrus nothing past
papyrus
hey if that [ __ ] was written past
papyrus
dude you know what the funny [ __ ] was
the part that made me die laughing
there's one person that's very
reasonable in there because when he was
talking about he doesn't read anything
that's man-made and he only reads
hieroglyphs yeah
somebody said but somebody had to write
those highlights
somebody wrote that somebody wrote those
hieroglyphs
and everybody ignored the most
reasonable person in the room
i was like is this is he [ __ ]
trolling everybody in this room
it's just like okay i guess the i guess
that's
what's the clubhouse club yes i guess
that's what clubhouse says
you guys have if you guys ever go on
clubhouse this is the one thing i would
i want to warn you guys about clubhouse
just because these people write stuff
that they do it doesn't mean that
they're an expert
in that topic or subject let me give you
a great example right i'm
you before you go on to clubhouse and
you get that invite right they ask you
what your interests are
it's much like pinterest right so based
on your interest they'll suggest certain
groups right so obviously my stuff is
finance business and whatever right
that's stuff that i'm somewhat
interested to hip hop music whatever
so one that popped up was how to grow a
successful business and make millions
i'm like cool so who are these people i
go in there it's these people who own
like one or two nail shops
right a liquor store here none of them
are millionaires
not and listen i'm not [ __ ] on the
small business i come from a small
business i have small businesses
but in order for you to give advice to
people about how to make seven figures
you have to make seven figures
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
it's it's the adult version of dumb
teens of dumb teen talk
right it's like these people are just
[ __ ] bullshitting each other the
whole time
and there was a subject about how to use
social media for your business and stuff
and i'm in social media and i use it for
my businesses and i actually have proof
that this stuff works
all their information was wrong it was
completely wrong and i went to go look
at some of these people's names and
their businesses
and their influencer page it's some of
the worst stuff i've ever seen
the worst interactions the worst
conversion everything that you could see
that's something that you shouldn't do
for a business they had it and they were
giving a seminar
about how to use social media to make
money and grow a seven-figure business
when they didn't have any of it
man so clubhouse is uh
i mean it's new but it's just
unregulated conference tables
and like where anyone could say it's
live twitter live twitter
it's live twitter it's a bunch of people
who think that and
by the way there are actually really
great ones yeah you just have to find
them
right but when you go into clubhouse and
people tell you it's great for
networking be careful about the
information that you're receiving
you can't think that these everybody in
there is a [ __ ] garyvee
they're they're not it's people who want
to sound smart or they're complaining
and griping about some type of social
injustice
right right which hey that's fine too
but at a certain point it just sounds
like a bunch of [ __ ] whining to me
you know
oh my god this is like the great intro
that i gave the clubhouse
i was like yeah it could be great it
could but uh you know
you know i'll i'll just kind of lurk
around for now now
if you guys want to yo i will say this
though there are some [ __ ]
but there's there was a clubhouse that i
looked into that khalif showed me and we
were dying laughing
it was called like triple x booty
clapping or something
and literally it's just somebody
clapping ass
literally just
and somebody else hops in and they're
talking dirty it's like these strippers
that opened up this
okay and there was like a thousand
people in that room and they was just
clapping at
dude we could open up a room and just do
that
call the triple x clapping ass it's like
oh we're gonna rub some baby
on this so [ __ ] funny dude clubhouse
is so ridiculous
but anyways um as per usual
uh you guys have been asking for a lot
of these like uh
film reviews and you know when we could
do film reviews we can obviously get
into a lot of american films that have
been coming out
but i want to share with you guys a lot
of korean films that i grew up with
classics yeah
i'm not like beating on this [ __ ] i'm
not beating the same drama trying to
show you guys like what these
like asian people can make great films
thems is just facts
but i want to share with you guys some
stuff that you haven't seen yes
you know um maybe you guys have seen
this there was once again an american
remake of this film
and i have talked about how i don't like
a lot of rom-coms
but there are a few that have stuck with
me for quite a long time
and my favorite favorite rom-com of all
time is actually a korean one and it's
called my sassy girl
right right
this rom-com it's
as a korean-american it's so creep
it's so creepy how similar it is to my
life it made me
it made me feel like there was a camera
watching my whole life and then they
made a film is this the truman show
yeah it felt like it right
dude i mean um i saw it a long time ago
i got i'm gonna
probably say 10 plus years ago and
um so i was pretty much a [ __ ] kid
yeah and um i wasn't into rom-coms at
all
um but i just watched it again
because you told me ed we're going to
watch my sassy girl
so i actually felt like here we go like
all right i'm gonna watch this rom-com
and you know what it was
[ __ ] hilarious dude it's great it's a
great film dude it's one of those
rom-coms that had moments that i
actually cried laughing
like because of how as it has those
moments it has these moments that are
so [ __ ] ridiculous it just made me
crack the [ __ ] up
like the main the uh i forgot the
actress's name
um i mean i i didn't look she was she
was famous though like she was like the
hottest korean actress at the time right
when she was doing this film let's see
jun ji hyun
yeah you're right i had the wikipedia
so many korean women are like here
yeah okay so you were talking about the
remake right and the main complaint was
that it doesn't have the soul or
whatever and i was watching the
trailer for the american remake and this
girl just sounds
crazy yeah just says these things it's
the same lines as the korean film but
her character sounds off her rocker
right but when we watch this film it's
like
i've dated a girl like this yeah i know
this girl this is the typical [ __ ]
angry ass korean girl that just tries to
soccer boyfriend
no matter what whether you're angry
you're happy you're sad korean girls
just like to [ __ ] hit you i have no
idea why
and then the other thing about this
movie is they really [ __ ] hit each
other in this movie they
really get hit which is great actually
yeah it turns out like
it's it's violent in a way but every
time someone gets hit it's hilarious
it's just
f that's just how korean girls are dude
they like to hit
like when they're happy with you they
suck you when they think you're cute
they suck you when they when they like
you they suck you even more
like what the [ __ ] is that about dude oh
man
so once again we're gonna do the i'll
read through
the synopsis and the plot and
david i know you love this movie and
seen this probably way more than i have
you probably want to take the reigns
more on we'll just read it down and then
we'll break it down so let's see uh the
film tells the love story of a male
engineering college student
and quote the girl her name is never
mentioned in the movie
hyonu just cannot seem to catch romantic
break
their personality stands opposite to the
character
characteristics traditionally associated
with masculinity
and femininity femininity
in asian societies in general
so it actually starts with three parts
and
it says first half right
one day at a dinner and drinks with his
college friends
jonu is interrupted by a call from his
mother telling him to visit his aunt and
meet a potential date
at the train station on his way to his
aunts he observes a drunk girl
standing precariously close to the edge
of the train platform
as the train approaches he pulls her to
safety just in time so
uh we we get an idea of who konu is
right he speaks about how he was raised
and the type of guy he is he's like an
admitted dope
he's kind of dumb yeah he's kind of
really stupid and it's so funny too
because
uh in that train scene too uh she's
she's literally teetering at the edge of
the subway and he kind of looks at her
and he runs to save her saves her and
she's just
wobbling back and forth stairs and she
goes
which means sweetie and she [ __ ]
you know this is like before this is
after she throws up right right right so
um he he tries to
like well first he helps her from like
falling off the edge and then they get
in the train
and then um she calls out the dude who's
sitting on the seat that's right right
so if you guys know and uh if you want
to explain
in korean culture so in korean culture
or any kind of like eastern culture we
have a reverence for our elders
right japan korea it's it's all the same
when you're on a kicha like a train like
a subway station right
if there's an elder person you let them
sit first and you stand
even in japan there's signs that say if
an elder person is there
you have to let them sit first and you
need to stand it's actually a rule
in the train and so there's this younger
person that's like
he's like chewing gum listening to music
or some [ __ ] right and there's an older
man and he's like coughing
um
and he kind of ignores the older dude
but this girl being the gangster that
she is
she just starts [ __ ] cursing this
dude out telling him to
get the [ __ ] up and let this old man sit
down the way she said it too
is is very kangpe like yeah right
yeah hey
you're not gonna get up [ __ ] slaps in
the back and it's
a real slap that's what i'm telling you
guys everybody gets slapped for real in
this movie
talk about slapstick it's for real yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends
what are you doing with your time 2021
you can spend it creating something
meaningful with skillshare's online
classes because time
is what we make of it so what are you
doing my friends with skillshare you can
find
inspiration in the moment and learn how
to express your
creativity right now i'm actually taking
a course called productivity for
creatives because your boy is
all over the place and sometimes when
you're creative like
productivity is the last thing that you
think about you're only thinking about
creating well
the problem with that is that if you're
not really focusing and kind of planning
out what you're going to do
you kind of just end up going in a
circle so this class has been helping me
out a lot especially when it comes to
this podcast
skillshare has a bunch of classes and
courses that you get to take
on your own time it's incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricey in-person classes and workshops
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month yes my friends it's that
cheap explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.combrain
once again
in order to get that trial of premium
membership go to
skillshare.com brain
she smacks him upside his head with the
force of a thousand suns
but um you'll notice like
and then so the old man sits but then
she gets drunk
and barfs on the old man's head it's so
graphic
oh my gosh but just to give like a
little insight into her personality
after she already checks his full first
and smacks him upside his head
she looks and she goes ah
which means like hey don't pee
doesn't look good on you because he's
wearing a pink polo shirt yeah so she
has to roast his fool about his shirt
and then he has to take that [ __ ] and
walk away
so uh
let's see inside the train konwu cannot
help us there the girl who is his type
but repulsed by her drunkenness
finally she throws up on a passenger and
faints but not before she calls
which means like honey honey right the
passenger
aggressively chides konu and tells him
to take care of his girlfriend
so um the obvious part is just like
drunkenness is very normal in korea
public drunkenness is a normal part of
korean life
right you see it all the time yeah um
specifically after hours too so like in
japan and korea
like everybody's kind of in the
corporate business world they're so used
to being very strict and very
like very stringent rules and kind of
like keeping up the joneses right but
when it's time to drink
after work which is in korean it's
called is where you drink with the
company
people get smashed and [ __ ] face dude
when me and dan were there
and even when i was in japan the year
after
every night anytime after midnight or
something
some aji some some salary man
passed out on the street passed out on
the bushes passed down
on the the park bench passed out on the
bus it's just part of the life you take
care of you just leave them alone
and then you just don't mind them yeah
like you know you guys will see that
sometimes if you're listening to this on
the east coast like in new york you see
these dudes that wake up the next
morning they're going into
their [ __ ] uh suit and tie job
but you could tell that they got smashed
the night before and they're still
wearing the same
suit that they wore the night before so
just that times ten it's like a bunch of
this
you'll see it in japan when you go in
tokyo you'll see it all the time right
yeah
did they in the beginning of the film
they they kind of went through his his
life as a kid right right
so he they they thought he was a girl
they wanted him to they wanted a girl so
they dressed him as a girl
so he thought he was a girl and he
didn't understand why he had a penis
though
so you want to know something [ __ ]
funny when i was watching this film
i i was mortified when that first came
out you know why so when i was a kid
this is a true [ __ ] story and i have
pictures of this uh
not too long ago i went back to
sacramento and
uh we were going through our old uh
photo albums right
i said this is not too long ago this is
way back in the day yeah but we revisit
this just to show muriel
so years ago and this is uh before i saw
the film
i was going through our old photo albums
and i noticed that my brother when he
was a kid too at the same time he wore
very different clothes than i did
yeah and i'm like why the [ __ ] is
everything that i'm wearing
pink with like flowers and bunnies and
why is it all pale yellow
and so my mom starts laughing and she
goes oh that's because we only dressed
you in girl clothes till you were like
two
i was like excuse me what did you just
say
my parents dressed me up as a girl
because
back in the day or people still do it
now when they looked at the shape of
your belly
that's how they would assume what gender
you were so because it was either oblong
shaped or really wide
they were saying that i was going to be
a girl and for them it was facts it was
empirical evidence
written in stone written stuff in higher
graphics
so everybody assumed that i was going to
be a girl
so i had clothes for kids ages one
through two that were all
girl clothes and we were too poor to buy
new clothes so i was dressed as a
[ __ ] girl for the first two years of
my life
damn so when i saw that in that film i
was mortified
but it kind of speaks to his character
right because
um he kind of has an overcompensation
kind of thing as a man
um but he can't he can't overpower this
girl
her masculinity is
way above his yeah um konu
completely flustered leaves her on a
subway platform bench
but his conscience compels him to take
her to the nearest hotel for safety
while the girl is passed out on the bed
her phone rings and konu picks up
he gives vague answers in regards to the
girl's whereabouts and perhaps
through gps tracking police raid the
room and kyonu gets maced and sent to
jail
talk about a [ __ ] who has no
foresight yeah so
it kind of talked about how he's just
he's not a he's a doctor
yeah this [ __ ] like
can't see ahead the problem of him
walking around naked
with this drunk drunk girl in this bed
and in between that too there's all
these small nuances like the way he
deals with the hotel
owner because he had like sextuplets and
like
yeah um all these little nuances so
the other thing i noticed about this
movie like if it had to be remade it
should have been remade by edgar wright
um the guy who made a hot fuzz oh yeah
yeah yeah
um baby driver right world's end
sean of the dead because i think you
mentioned the guy who does every frame
of painting
did a repo a whole essay on edgar wright
and i was i was watching this movie i
was like this is a korean edgar wright
movie
that's what it is all those like
everything has a joke to it yeah
every setup everything that's going to
it every little moment there's no time
wasted
that's why this is such a great like
comedic film by the way this is what i
really appreciate about it
so this [ __ ] anyway gets caught
in a situation where
it looks like he's gonna bill cosby this
girl
and it's so this part cracked me up is
because it just goes to show
how stupid he is because even in this
dire situation he already kind of put
himself in this like [ __ ] situation
right
he does there's no way that he looks
good in this he starts
so cops in korea don't have guns
um from what i was told is like the
people who do have guns are higher up
like right like um
investigate detectives right detectives
have guns or something like that but
your
your regular just beating the cop
doesn't they have like whatever sticks
and they have mace
and so this female cop comes in and sees
him butt naked right
she's telling him to raise his hands to
put his hands up but he sees this is a
woman cop
but his dick's out so it covers his head
she's like no
put his head back over her so he gets
[ __ ] mace in the eyes
all right [ __ ] up situation so
um he's
he uh spends a night in jail and uh he
gets caught up with these
gangpets uh in there which pretty much
kind of once again i think it's setting
up
uh showing his quote-unquote masculinity
yeah in their society where he kind of
stands
let's say quote unquote beta yeah yeah
yeah
the beta type yeah he is sent home from
jail the next morning
and to a surprise he gets a phone call
from the girl who demands
they meet by the train station so he can
figure out what happened the night
before
so they go to baskin robbins and he
explains to her
what exactly happened that night before
and as it plays out and then the
the camera sucker circles around and
then it zooms out
the story that of what just happened to
them there was a kid's birthday party
and then it's empty
once again these visual comedy cues
these little small
little little like nuances to it it's
just so real so funny
and rich in korean culture just nuanced
korean like humor
it also kind of in that moment too it
just shows how clueless he is too
right right because he doesn't even know
how much time has passed and he looks
like
oh or like his spatial awareness yes
he's telling this really weird story
around little kicky little kids
head of baskin robbins so
so they just uh she tells him you know
uh that they're gonna go get drinks
right so
over soju the girl cries admits to
breaking up with her boyfriend the day
before
and gets thoroughly drunk resulting in a
second trip to the same hotel
thus begins his comically ill-fated
relationship with the girl
so um in that restaurant she calls out
these creeps
oh yeah at the restaurant okay so this
is a pattern of behavior because even in
the subway we said before
she has a righteous anger yeah that's
[ __ ]
hard yeah we have a reason to be angry
there's a lot of virtue in it yeah like
um
because of the uncontrollable anger like
if something is wrong you know that
someone with the
that han is gonna just do what they can
to say something about it right there
and that's her
like balls out calls out these [ __ ]
creeps with these younger girls like
these junior high students
right and uh she kind of walks up to
them and immediately just goes up and
says where's your id
yeah she tries to age check these kids
and then um
the older men obviously they know
they're doing something [ __ ] creepy
they're picking up on these young girls
who by the way these girls know what
they're doing too they almost go off as
like little prostitutes
yes right and so he's like no no no like
oh you you got it completely wrong these
are just my little tongs right
like which is like my little siblings
yeah right which it clearly isn't
you know they're in it because they're
gonna get free drinks and beer and you
know they just entertain these old [ __ ]
yeah so um
while she's doing that it also disturbs
the other
you know people in there right while she
might be doing like throughout this
whole film she's so
public she's so like doesn't matter she
doesn't give
a [ __ ] like she's gonna do what she's
gonna do
right okay so
comes back super upset about you know
what what had just happened
with these uh men and these girls and
she makes him poor drink and then
one shot like on on cue i mean on film
this is a one take thing she takes three
shots
right and then she starts confessing
about her past relationship
and then boom
[ __ ] smashes her head to the table
dude
this dude this part he's [ __ ]
freaking out
just poking her he's having a [ __ ]
anxiety breakdown dude like please
please wake the [ __ ] up
the way he pokes at her too did you see
his desperation
like please just wake up oh man
um let's see where are we now drunk she
uh she's drowning her sorrows in alcohol
obviously
and um she he takes her back
to the hotel um he gets a little poet
poetic in a weird way i saw her
face her neck and her breasts
was like appreciating the beauty yeah
just just as a quote-unquote beta right
and then then he gets very determined
like he knows this girl
must be really sad yeah that's why she's
getting drunk she's
really hurt and he's now determined
to fix her sorrows yeah right
right so
after the second overstay night at the
hotel she begins
to become a more active part of his life
she visits kyonmu in college and pulls
him out of class
telling the teacher that kony was the
father too
too soon to be imported baby
yo
this scene was
i was like is this the best abortion
joke i've ever seen
so they have to go to the clinic dark is
that
and like right before he like he's
vehemently denying this
and clearly nobody believes in the and
the professor looks them right before he
leaves he goes
if you can keep it just keep it you got
to raise her as your own if you can't
yeah but when she
said it she was like he was like she's
like how how'd you
i should convince him to get me out of
class oh i said we're gonna go get an
abortion
let's go yeah this girl's crazy dude
she's crazier than the girl in fight
club dude you know what's so [ __ ]
funny too like when i remember when i
saw that too like later on
this happened to me um after but
i broke up with somebody this actually
happened twice but this one was very
similar to this one
i broke up with somebody right and this
was like in my car
in my own podcast for shane um
and this is we were parked in a car and
i was gonna
call it quits with this girl she was but
and i [ __ ] you not when i say crazy i
don't use this term
loosely unless it's a joke towards what
this girl was [ __ ] nuts like she had
some mental issues right right
great sex crazy that's why you stay
though
so you know when i was calling it quits
you know we're doing the face this is in
sacramento
she starts [ __ ] bawling
uncontrollably in the car
like it looked like i struck her dude
and so
i'm freaking out right i'm like yo calm
down she was like no
no and she just starts crying bawling
and this is this is just to show by the
way
dating two weeks yeah
two weeks unwarranted that should not be
a reaction for some guy you know for two
weeks yeah
starts crying uncontrollably right and
this person
walks by the car and you know what she
says she goes do right by her
i'm like i didn't hit i didn't do
anything i know you do right by her
she just walks off in the most sassiest
way possible i'm like yo
dude i didn't do anything dude
oh man so uh it's a crazy story
um because you and i have dated korean
girls
like i said this crazy is kind of
no we understand it we know it right
uh i'm not gonna say it's normal but we
know it
familiar um yeah i was in a position
where like i was fighting with this girl
outside it takes my horse yeah of course
tigs
and we're just having an argument and
about some
[ __ ] and i'm just like
why are you being like this and then she
starts
crying you know and she falls to the
floor
she goes i had an abortion
screen out loud in the middle if you
know where tiggs is it's pioneer square
right pine
squirrel is like yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ]
hey hey let's let's go get up let's go
let's go right
i'm going to finish this story as we
move along with this movie okay
i'm going to leave that right there and
i'm going to get on with this story
because we're going to talk about the
familiarity of how crazy korean girls
are okay
oh my god i just my ass is sweating from
that dude
like literally my ass is sweating from
that [ __ ]
oh man so well well back to the movie
let's see
where was i uh the girl's moon swings
wildly from
joyful to downright violent but kyonmu
puts up with it
and lets her abuse lets her let her let
her abuse him
for her amusement so
she also turns out to be an aspiring
scriptwriter
and throughout the movie she gives gonu
three different screenplays
and different genres the first is an
action movie
the demolition terminator oh my god
which switches gender roles symbolically
having the girl
save her helpless lover which is kyonu
and second is a wild perversion of a
korean short story
uh oh how do you call how do you
pronounce it is a
sudden rain shower flash flood right
yeah
in which the girl having died asked that
her lover be buried along with her
even though he's still alive
so these two like what they kind of do
a like um i don't know what you call it
like community like
they he reads the script but then it
comes to life and they have this big
action scene now
mind you this is 2001 in korea i think
treaty came out like two years before
yeah and it was like the biggest box
office hit in korea at the time right
yeah 99
because korea didn't have an action
movie like that before right
and uh they kind of wrote on that with
this movie with this girl wanting to be
a screenwriter
and she's expressing the story
super cheesy and corny but then they
have this shootout together where she
like saves them which is like it's super
cute
yeah it's nice and then she tells the
story of sonaki
is one of the most that surprisingly
this is probably there's so many
great moments in this film this play out
of
this screenplay was one of my favorite
parts of this film
because it depicts first of all how
[ __ ] nuts she is
so it's like it's like set in olden
times right
and obviously this is pre-dates like
modern medicine or whatever right
and you know they kind of make these
promises to each other like you're going
to be with me till the day
i die all right you know and it's like
stuff that you say when you're extremely
in love with somebody right but nobody
takes these words for it to be
like literal right so
she dies right what was it from was it
from like it was from something nobody
knows right yeah but then her last dying
wish is that she's buried with her lover
and then it cuts to like you know
traditional korean funerals just
people are crying in the background
right and then people are putting dirt
in
and they're dragging into the [ __ ]
hole
to bury what they bury him alive
and then he tries to drag and they
[ __ ] hit him in the face of the show
twice twice dude visual comedy
the pacing the the style the
the timing oh my goodness when you guys
watch this film
you're gonna under you're gonna re-watch
my sketches and understand where i get
like
where my comedy from right it's it's as
korean as korean gets
it's literally from movies like this
right so let's do it the part
so after she's like done reading this
whole story right they're playing the
whole thing out
it goes back to them in the cafe and you
look at kion's face he's mortified
and her face is like in this dream state
she thinks that she just told the story
about what true love is
like what the [ __ ] is going on
he's he's just like what the [ __ ]
but after telling the story of
her screenplay well she's realizing
through it though like this is why it's
just great storytelling they use this
hilarious scene to set up the fact that
she's not over her
ex right um and
because of that it makes her a bit
sadistic
so she pushes konu over the talk and he
can't swim
yeah and she watches him drown
he's literally drowning to death like ah
that's how deep it is it's so sadistic
and then she dives in and saves him and
then she goes in and saves him
he gets tired of her [ __ ] and enacts
revenge
by ditching her and forcing her to take
care of him when he's drunk but he ends
up in jail again
she picks him up from jail instead and
beats the [ __ ] out of him
so going back to the story i was just
telling
um we were in a fight outside of tiggs
and she starts crying saying that she
had an abortion
insult and it was like really loud she
screams in front of everyone so i
i hold her by the arms i'm like hey what
are you talking about
what are you talking about tell me what
are you talking my baby what
right and then she takes her hand
and i just see a [ __ ] fist come right
at me it was like slow-mo
you know like i play baseball right yeah
when you see a ball that's going to hit
you
it's almost in slow-mo you actually see
the ball before you get hit
that fist was right in my face and went
bam
and it was like white for a second and
then
i looked at her and then another fist
bam right in my face she sucked you she
sucked me right in my face right outside
it takes
and then i looked at i was like what
stop hitting me and
and i had to grab her hand finally i'm
holding both her wrists
stop hitting me yeah and then you know
what she says
ew stop yelling at me
my sassy girl bro you two you think like
this [ __ ] is crazy
i get it i [ __ ] get it
she went ew stop yelling at me
and she left to her car and
oh and then i didn't continue there's a
i couldn't believe it i was like my face
is like
my head is spinning my world is like i
just woke up
like where am i oh i'm at tiggs dude i
gotta
i literally you guys will see this in a
film that i'm kind of writing right now
and it's literally about the
relationship that marilyn and i have had
marilyn is not like that but she has
glimpses of these things right
so i don't think i've ever told a story
before because i want to leave in the
script but i'll just tell now you'll see
it in the film either way yeah
but marilyn and i when we first started
going out
we had a lot of these like very crazy
fights and arguments right
and uh muriel back in the day she's not
like this
anymore but she didn't like it when
somebody that she cared about disagreed
with her right
because it made it if to her it sounded
like we were belittling her if we just
didn't agree with the stuff that she
liked
right and since and this is like our
first year or two that we've been
together right and
you know me growing in a household where
we tend to yell a lot
i got super frustrated with her so i
don't
can't remember exactly what it is right
now i have it written down somewhere
because that's how funny this situation
is to me later on
but literally i said hey let's just
agree to disagree let's just have a good
dinner right
and uh it ended up her just yelling at
me she was like nope you need to tell me
that i'm a good person
right and i'm like what are you doing
right she goes say i'm a good person
right now and i'm like
uh no like don't talk to me like that
don't make demands to me i was like
we don't have to agree about everything
let's just agree to disagree it's not a
big deal
right let's just move on she goes say
i'm a good person she's yelling at me at
this point
and i looked at her and i was like hey
look i'm actually getting angry right
now
so i need you to calm down let's relax
and we'll just have a good meal we'll
talk about this later okay
she goes say i'm a good person say i'm a
good she's just saying it over and over
and over right
and i turn to her i go shut the [ __ ]
up because she's been screaming at me
right and then she stops she goes
why are you yelling
let me tell you i got so mad i grabbed
the collar of my shirt and i tore my
shirt in half
because i didn't know what to do
you know it's like you're like
speechless i bet if you had a bowl of
dirt next to you you put a portion of
your head like
like i just wanted to beat myself up
it's like reality
you were yelling at me for like
five minutes straight and i go yell back
at you and you go oh my god this guy's
crazy
oh my god
we that was like one of the [ __ ]
funniest moments that oh man
and you know what and we love these
people
and i [ __ ] love this woman to death
welcome to korean rom-com yep
all right um man
man uh so crazy let's see where we leave
off
she he ditches her to hang out with his
friends and drink and she calls him
and there's that scene when he did the
english
uh [ __ ] voicemail the number you have
a dial
is not in a service please hang up and
call it game
and at the jail she comes your english
is pretty good huh
yeah that's what it was
so he was like out drinking with his
friends and he sees this hot girl walk
by right and he's like
[ __ ] this last girl i'm over her i'm i'm
a holler at the next fine chick i see
and this finest girl walks by
and he's like uh i gotta see it you know
we're just like hey baby
it's he freaks out starts running away
and she's like and she looks looks for
him and he ditches her and that's when
he does the
voicemail he does the [ __ ] voice tone
dial thing
and that's when he gets drunk to teach
her a lesson finds him there she goes
your english is pretty [ __ ] good huh
yeah
please let me be cold again oh my god
and um there's some foreshadowing there
when he's in the bar uh on the news that
says
a soldier went awol um
and um it also sets up the next scene in
between that
um after he's bailed out of jail
his dad keeps trying to bust him for
watching porn oh yeah
it's so like random like why is this
scene happening
but it it doesn't matter it's hilarious
because it's just setting up the fact
that he gets an email from her
but just great filmmaking just how do
you tell a story about a guy getting an
email
about his dad trying to catch him
watching porn
genius it's genius great filmmaking
these things too are so
small and subtle but it's so [ __ ]
funny because it's very real too yeah
like
we used to watch porn and then we're
always looking over our shoulders to
make sure our dad doesn't know
but his dad's not even angry because he
has no proof
he's just bored and he goes like he
comes in he goes like a sweet sweet
father right he's like
you're not watching any porn or anything
are you yeah what do you mean i'm not
doing any of that stuff
and he goes back to watching port and he
plugs right back in
he's like what are you doing he goes uh
just you know i'm just checking whatever
gosh so
despite all the horrible things killing
with nerds he is determined to cure
the girl's pain he decides to surprise
her on her birthday
and takes her on a nighttime trip to an
amusement park
which ends up quite differently from how
he planned
the pair encounter the awol soldier who
holds them hostage
and rants about his misery after being
jilted
konu convinces him to release her and
she in turn convinces a soldier to free
konu
and go on with his life and pursue
pursue another love
so this part is obviously like um
well going let's turn back um this story
started off as a
blog right yeah this dude who was coping
with
his breakup with this girl and he was
telling stories about this crazy girl
that he was dating
and eventually that blog turned into
this novel a fictionalized novel which
turned into this script which turned
into this movie
yeah and
obviously this part i don't know if it's
true i don't think it is
but like i said before the part with his
dad trying to
bust him for watching porn um
it it doesn't say much except it's just
funny
but it sets it up for the fact um that
he's uh
for the next scene yeah i feel like this
whole thing is like an
exaggerated fictional way to um
show their first fight between a third
person probably who also had a breakup
yeah and then ended up with them because
what it
really showed with this soldier in him
was that throughout this
whole time in this movie this is a
halfway point of the movie
konu can't admit that he's dating this
girl yeah
even though all his friends think that
this girl is the hottest girl out there
way above his league and all that he
just can't admit that
he's dating this girl he won't even tell
his teacher or anybody around him no i'm
not dating her
and when this [ __ ] soldier has a gun
pointed to his head he can't even say no
i'm not dating her
yeah so they all went into um i guess
after hours they wanted to
break into this uh carnival or you know
amusement park like look the world or
something like that right and so
this this uh runaway military dude
he goes into the quote-unquote not so
much abandoned but the closed amusement
park
and that's where they decide that they
wanted to go find them takes them
hostage
and you get to see like how how actually
kind of like compatible and cute they
are right
even before you get to see the moment
where he kind of just you can see he
doesn't want to admit that that's his
girlfriend
and even in the midst of her
being in hostage with a guy with an
automatic rifle to her head
she's still a [ __ ] gangster yeah this
is how scary this woman is right
because she was like oh because he asked
like if they're together right
and she goes he goes uh we're not really
together or he kind of alludes to that
right and he says something in a very
crude way he goes could they get tamago
to the dead and then he's like so can i
[ __ ] her then
right and she looks at them she goes
what am i some [ __ ] fruit like they
just pick me like that you can just pick
me like that
but then there's such a funny part too
where there's this moment
where he's where you think kion is going
to do something manly because he's such
a beta [ __ ] in this film right
where he's going to say it's kind of a
lose to the fact that he might say to
like hey you know what
if you can't let both of us go can you
at least
let me go
just gonna yeah you think that he's
gonna man up
and sacrifice himself he [ __ ]
sacrifices her yeah
and then he hurt he hears that and now
this military guys is even more pissed
because that cowardly like behavior
reminds him of the girl of the guy that
his girl left them for
that moment right there i was like yo
this guy is such a [ __ ] throughout this
whole film
but um i think it plays along too with
the way
i think it might be a little meta too
because
before we were seeing the action film
and we were seeing the sonagi
film and now like i feel like
you know he's throwing a little hostage
situation filmmaking
action thing in the middle of this kind
of
um core it's literally the
um climax of the
first yeah for the movie right and um
because it's it's a surprise supposed to
be a surprise birthday for the girl
and konu's friend who works at the
amusement park
sees oh konu so he lights off the
fireworks when this guy's trying to kill
him
like it turns out to be this
melodramatic moment right
earlier he was given telling the girl
like
oh you're you're your story's not sad
enough it doesn't have the melodrama
koreans love melodrama
and in this moment in a meta way
the screenwriter put melodrama
yeah in this action scene i think that
was a
pretty great way of telling this story
of their first fight like a big big
fight
about their relationship and but what
ultimately happens
though is that it strengthens their
relationship
right so
the girl in uh tony's relationship
turns a turn for the better her cruel
treatment okionu
is her way of showing affection and the
two grow closer
let's see and uh she presents another
script to konu
and this time it's more of like a wusha
like samurai movie
and um all
the way it kind of goes off it's it's
like super action filled and
this and that but then the point of all
three of these scripts that she keeps
bringing up is that this girl is from
the future
yeah she has this obsession
with the future right and
what's to come or meeting people from
the future and it's
and it's kind of showing off in these
scripts that she keeps writing
and she she makes him go
to a production company to hand over the
script
oh my god this is so bad it makes this
guy like
a r guy starts reading it
he starts heaving yeah because of how
terrible it is
he turns the page
dude this is the visual guy i'm telling
you you guys though
like everything is a joke yeah
everything has its moment for a joke
and the good thing about this film too
sometimes when you see uh films who do
jokes every two seconds you kind of get
exhausted right
uh one of a great example is and a lot
of people disagree with me on this is
like
because i loved like taekwontiti right
but when he did the thor film i thought
he did
too many jokes where it was like i liked
that it was enjoyable i still liked the
film a lot
but sometimes it was like thor always
had to say some kind of quick witty joke
the last word
yeah it's like really yeah like can we
just move on like
it happened like 80 times throughout the
film and that's when i feel like
sometimes they're not placing these
jokes very well
it's like it's funny but you it's not
funny when you have to do it all the
time
this film does it in so many different
ways like you kind of just don't
know when to expect the joke well the
problem being that the
jokes like you're describing is off of
improv yeah
thor four feels very important yeah
right but this
film is like you have to script you have
to write this joke down
yeah and they they thought
they thought about all these things that
every little thing can be funny
yeah and which is great that's why they
say it's a korean
[ __ ] abortion joke for crying out
loud dude even for his time it wasn't
that controversial but even then it's
like goddamn yeah
you know okay so
um they play the game on the train where
if someone
steps over with their left or right foot
they slap each other face and that's a
whole setup for himself you guys have to
see it for yourself it's a great scene
they sign up for kendo they play uh
racquetball right or squash and
um she makes him wear her heels
and chase her around like or then if he
doesn't do it what happens
it gets pissed pissed it's this little
thing that you see like cute korean
couples do is
just like come and catch me and i know
and you know what the funny thing is
like i've never had a girl ask me to do
this until i met mariel
like i'm like replaying my sassy girl in
my head as she asked me to do this at
disneyland
she goes she goes
catch me if you can you know like i'm
not like i'm lovey-dovey but i'm not
that lovey-dovey especially in a public
place like that
so i'm looking at her and i remember at
digital and she goes nine times she goes
on table you're not gonna catch me she
goes
fine whatever and she's like pissed i'm
like oh my god this is the film all over
again
i'm like yo what is going on she's
taking her cues
yeah so i think um
does does mario ever think that you have
the ability to read her mind
yes all the time yes and so same with
this card
oh my gosh korean girls is it or is it
every girl i don't know but
for me every korean girl that i've uh
dated was
they thought that i was supposed to read
their mind but you don't know
but oh my god she's so real right
yeah all right so
after a day of hanging out he walks her
home in the pouring rain
and she demands that he meet her father
who is a habitual drinker her parents do
not take keonu
and uh do not take to kyonu
and on leaving he he overhears
an impassioned argument between the girl
and her mother over her relationship
with him
he does not hear her from her damn
i'm i must be twisted not drunk i can't
read this [ __ ]
he does not hear her
he does not hear from her for quite some
time
and his life without her begins so they
break up because her parents don't
approve of him
damn i couldn't read that [ __ ] you can
see like where you get how
why she her her lightweightness from her
drinking comes from her father
it's just he passes out and smashes his
head to the table too it's like
that's where she got it from right and
um you can see
uh it's it's not a normal two to have a
drink with
the father of the girl you meet either
right
knocks out right
so um like i was saying earlier uh
mariel kind of expects you to read her
mind but
have you ever had a moment of just like
no communication or in past
relationships where just like
someone just ghosted you i mean i've
definitely
yes my very very first girlfriend she
ghosted me for two weeks
and then broke up with me after damn
that [ __ ] was
one of the most like emotionally like
[ __ ] moments of my life
as a [ __ ] 19 year old could you
imagine what that's like right as a 19
year old
like i i was gutted that happened to me
when i was 21 and that [ __ ] hurt too
yeah yeah it's like why would you do
that
you [ __ ] cuntbag like so i'm in that
moment too what happened was like i
the reason why it was so hard for me
when i was younger at that age was
because
the night the night before that she just
ghosted me for two [ __ ] weeks
i said something to her that was kind of
the nail in the coffin it was true
though
it's it's actually how i felt right but
it was something that i didn't want to
accept
and i set it out of impulse because we
were having an argument
right and so i was i remember i was at
my buddy daryl's house
and uh i went to go crash at his place
because i wanted to check out you know
torrance because i was in riverside so i
went
home with him for the weekend to see
where he lived and stuff like that so
we're
chilling in at night and i go like
are we even compatible like is this even
working
like you and i are so different like i
don't understand
why we're so different and do you really
think that this is going to work
and then she got dead silent right right
and then i was like hey this is
something that you should think i woke
up the next morning and i was like
man i was just being emotional like i
shouldn't have said that yeah
she ghosted me for two weeks right and
so i said something to her that i think
was a big fear
and it just kind of reaffirmed what she
already felt and what i said wasn't
wasn't not true it was true we were not
compatible we didn't make sense
right she ghosted me for two weeks and
then she um
finally hits me up and i'm in sacramento
back from break
from riverside because she went to davis
yeah and then she goes hey can we meet
up
and i already know in my [ __ ] gut
this [ __ ] is gonna dump me
right and i'm like hey man i got what's
my exit plan i gotta make sure that she
doesn't dump me
and i kid you not this is like one of
the sorriest moments of my life this is
why i remind myself of coney like a
little [ __ ]
she breaks up with me right and i told
this to edric on the podcast but
she literally says it's not gonna work
she starts crying right let me tell you
what i did
not like a like a manly man i didn't be
like you know what i understand
bro i collapsed on my knees and i
grabbed her ankles
and i was like don't leave me no no and
i'm dead as a 19 year old grown-ass six
foot dude i was like
i grabbed her ankles like trying to
shackle her
please like i i'll do better don't leave
me and i just remember looking at me
she's crying
and i'm looking at myself when i look
back at that i'm like you should have
just
stepped in front of a car yeah you're a
[ __ ] loser dude
what is wrong with you i literally
grabbed her ankles like so she couldn't
oh my god
so one day however
the girl calls him and tells him to
bring her a rose during class
[ __ ] calls him after ghosting him
what do you know
to commemorate their 100th anniversary
after costing
she's crazy [ __ ] crazy dude
he does this leading to a touching a
romantic
scene where he arrives in disguise as a
food delivery person
in a packed auditorium and watches her
play the melody
of canon andy
he presents her the rose and the two hug
while classmates applaud in approval at
his romantic gesture
as part of the celebration they hit the
bars and clubs together dressed in high
school uniforms
she gets drunk as konu carries her on
his back a stranger slips a condom
konu drops her off inside and is
confronted at her
her house by her appearance again the
father interrogates him and forces him
to empty his pockets
where he embarrassing embarrassingly
presents the condom
and her father demands that the two
break up
so it was going to work
and then with the family
just the family got in the way and had
to break it were you ever in that kind
of situation where family was just like
i don't think marielle's mom liked me
very much really like when she first met
me she was very distant and cold
actually only until uh recently and mind
you she and i have been together for
about like six years
i think it was like uh last year where i
remember i
so when i was see her she would actually
never give me a hug
right and so i'm like and i understand
too right from a from a traditional
korean perspective
on the exterior i'm a piece of [ __ ]
but when you know me i'm very much not
like the persona that you probably see
in entertainment right
because this is entertainment yeah so
and everybody knows about me like
specifically
even in the church they know like i'm
this loud kid but they always said like
i
like her aunts even said this about me
she goes like you're a very kind soul
like that's what her aunt's always said
so her aunts love me from the get-go
right right because they saw my videos
they saw how much i cursed or whatever
but they met me and they go oh you have
a very kind soul right but i don't think
her mom really kind of bought into that
but then out of nowhere like last year
she sees me she goes david hug she gave
me
i was like what the [ __ ] what happened
what happened i don't know
i don't know what happened but i think
from uh perspective-wise just like kyonu
that's why i'm saying this
this film is really weird her mom
expected her to be with somebody who was
academically on paper very successful
right a doctor
a lawyer had a very stable nine-to-five
job right
so my what i did years ago to kind of
put this at ease
i was like oh you guys should come to
the grand opening of my matcha shop yeah
right because i don't think she knew
exactly what i did there was like 800
people there
and she's like uh what is this i was
like well they're here to see me
yeah you know you know oh and so she
i think her dad was like oh [ __ ] yeah
like he's not just some clown he's like
no i
i work like that he did
yeah i've had girls ask me wait what do
you do exactly
just so i can tell my parents
yeah it's like even now too when people
ask what i do they go what do you do for
a living i was like i'm a small business
owner
yeah that's what i say it's just what am
i supposed to do it's like i i get half
naked on my instagram
that's a good way to put it yeah all
right
the girl does not contact him again
and konu naturally thinks they have
broken up
until one day seemingly out of the blue
she calls konu to meet
her for dinner as she is on a blind date
the girl introduces to the date
who thinks konu is a great friend of
hers based on how highly she speaks of
him
she is unusually soft and gentle as
there is clear awkwardness between the
two
she excuses herself to the washroom
appears to not be handling the breakup
so well
so you know what they did a really good
job at and when i watched the film again
later on
is her wardrobe right she's dressed in
pure white
yeah do you know that like she's she's
an all-white
she looks it's like her being like this
pure
version of herself right like the whole
tuba idea yup
yeah and she's just all and dressed in
white
almost angelic and that's how she's
behaving it's like oh how odd
you know man even symbolically in colors
in korean dance damn you notice that
[ __ ] um
i don't know about you but i've been
trapped by my ex
to [ __ ] meet some other dude that i
wasn't
trying to meet i was trying to meet her
oh that was the reason why we got in
this fight in front of tiggs
oh i was living here and i had just
moved here right i was like two months
into la
and i went back to seattle to hang out
and i called her out it's hey cause we
were seeing each other
she just [ __ ] visited me in la so i
went back to see how let's hang out
and when i call her out to hang out she
[ __ ] brings a dude with her
pigs and so that's why we got in a fight
and that's why she said that [ __ ]
and that's why she punched me in the
face like
crazy wait why did was she saying that
that kid was your kid
or what did she just scream that she had
an abortion she just screamed that she
had an abortion and i was asking her was
it mine and when i did she punched me in
the [ __ ] face
what what was i'm sorry afterwards did
you guys talk about it like
[ __ ] sucked me so how sassy girl is
this so i call her the next morning
and she was like whoa i was so drunk
last night i don't know
oh my gosh and i told her exactly what
just like in the baskin robbins i told
her what she did right
and she goes yeah i was just lying yeah
i
know i'm just yeah i was like oh my god
i'm like
this girl is crazy you're a [ __ ]
psychopath and this is where we broke up
too
that's [ __ ] what is wrong with her
dude and now she's all powerful this
story will keep going as
this synopsis keeps going okay she's now
the head pastor
at a presbyterian church i'll finish it
all right all right and um
the girl returns to the table to see
kono gone
he left while she was in the bathroom
but not before
offering the blind day 10 rules to
follow to ensure
her happiness at a cafe instead of coke
juice order coffee prevent her from over
drinking after three drinks
given to uh her every circumstances
just all these little nuanced things
that we saw her with her weird behavior
he's telling this guy hey play a lot
this is what she likes
yeah right while the
blind date recites these rules to her
she realizes how well
kyonu understands her and realizes her
love for him
she abruptly leaves her date and
searches for konu at the subway station
they cross paths several times but never
run into each other
so she goes into the subway security
office to see the security monitors
she sees him standing close to the edge
of the platform
just like she was in the beginning while
an employee
makes an announcement in the microphone
she yells his name
he hears and they reunite at the office
right once reunited the two realize
they are at a turning point in their
relationship
but for some unknown reason the girl
decides it is time for them to part
as a gesture to their happy times the
two write letters to each other and bury
them
in a time capsule under a particular
tree
on a mountain in the countryside they
agreed to meet again
at the tree after two years to read
their letters together
after burying the time cancel time
capsule they go to their separate ways
for good
so you told your sad breakup stories
you got another one for us i mean that
was probably
after that that was the only sad breakup
i've ever had so the reason why
is because the very first girlfriend
that i had uh
she is was a life lesson for me it was a
reflection and how much of a loser i
am so taking that lesson
i said i would never be in that position
ever again
right not so much be vulnerable to
somebody right but to make sure that i
have my wits about me first that i
understand the value of myself first
before i go ahead and bring somebody
back into my life
or if things aren't going to work out
just cut it out like
define those lines really fast right
which led to later on me having a lot of
funny and weird dating stories because i
would literally date anybody and
everybody right anybody that would date
me i said yes
yeah right specifically number one and i
mentioned this before was like i
as a comic i needed life stories yeah
but i kept on doing this thing where i
wanted to fall magically in love with
somebody
but i'm like hold on you got to know
what you're in for so why don't you just
start dating people and so that's why
like
i mean i could probably fill up 30 000
episodes with every single date i've
been on
because i literally would just try to
mac on every single girl and whatever
girl would say yes i would go on a date
with them and see what would happen
right so after her i never had my heart
broken by another girl besides her
yeah i had my moment like that when i
was like 21
in uh in seattle we were uh
there's this really popular uh popular
street
near uw called the ave and it's where
all the restaurants and coffee shops are
and i met with my ex there
and i begged her they're in public to
take me back to
i was bawling my eyes out and crying in
front of
all these people and it was so awkward
that
she just got up and left and i was just
sitting there crying
oh my god i felt so sad for myself that
i walked out
the restaurant i walked down this street
the app and there are thousands of
people and i'm just
just crying until i get to my car i
always cried at my house
when i got to my house i put my blanket
and pinned up
up because the windows of my room was
completely dark to allow myself to cry
longer
home who was this like your first love
yeah my first love
yeah she was my very first love too
definitely i thought i took a bad dude
god damn man and that was part of one of
those things where i was like
reevaluating who i was as a person yeah
and like the kind of shitty person i was
and why
i was an [ __ ] why i wasn't good
enough
yeah then iraq and then you left to iraq
anyway let's see
um overtime now
uh two years have passed
uh during the two years konwu works hard
to improve himself
he practices kendo and racquetball or
squash
and learns to swim past the time he also
began writing about his dating
experiences with the girl on the
internet as a means to cope so he starts
reading the real life
or like playing out the real life parts
of the story
his stories gain so much notoriety that
he is approached by movie producers to
turn his letters into a movie
he is ecstatic because the girl's
lifelong dream was to have one of her
screenplays made into a film
he so desperately wants to share his
this news with her
but chooses to wait until they agreed to
meet
two years oh by the way so when he
presents the new script to that same a
r dude this time he's like floating in
mid-air
yeah oh man these little visual kills
cues man
please watch this movie you guys two
years have passed
and on the grid date he travels to the
tree on the mountain top but the girl
does not show up
he comes day after day without opening
the time capsule in hopes that
she would appear but she never does
eventually he opens the time capsule
and reads her letter and learns the root
of her angst and behavior
kuonu reminds her of her previous
boyfriend who
rather than breaking up with her
actually died before she met konu
on the day they met on the trains uh
platform
she was supposed to go on a blind date
set up by her
by the mother of her deceased boyfriend
with whom she kept
a close bond because of her chance
meeting with
konu part of her feels that it was her
ex that brought them two together
and she develops guilt of falling in
love with him
she needs time apart to heal and move on
from her ex alone so she decides to
break up
to do the mature thing to have to be
alone from him
to have to grow up yeah right and get
through her past
and she starts explaining about why
she's so obsessed with the future
right and this time capsule and because
she wants to move on
from the past but because she's stuck
from the past yeah
that's beautiful where these are real
human feelings that we feel right
because when when we get hit with trauma
we're in a time machine
every time we will replay this thing
that happened
10 15 20 30 years ago yeah
that's our time machine yeah and so now
so that's why she's obsessed with the
future she wants to move he wants to
move on really bad
and just in like perfect fashion how
they make everything into a [ __ ] joke
like
this tree that's so symbolic of their
relationship right they see this old man
right it's kind of like up right you
think that he's gotten old
you assume that that's kyodu but it's
not
i was like yo no this movie's genius
dude they [ __ ]
set me up so bad for that i was like oh
man they didn't come back after two
years
like it's been like 80 years no it was
just another year
it was like one year oh my gosh
so um
let's see sometime later the girl is on
a train
and the door closes right before a man
tries to board she has her back turned
to him she doesn't realize this
who realizes it is her and chases the
train down the platform to no avail
they fail to cross paths again so
between this time it's implying that
i mean they live in the same city that
they've crossed paths multiple times
yeah
but that they were in that moment like
perhaps before they were never meant to
be which is why i was so chaotic
yeah and right now when they choose not
to be together that whatever fate
decides is that they shouldn't be
together
it's a it's a great storytelling device
yeah
so as it turns out the girl is on her
way to lunch with her deceased
boyfriend's mother
who has planned to introduce the girl to
her nephew for a blind date
the nephew arrives and it turns out to
be konu
as it turns out konu is the boy that she
had been trying to introduce to the girl
for years
the mother offers reasons as to why
they'd be great match for one another
but konu and the girl are too busy
gazing into each other's eyes
and the mother asks do you know each
other and the camera pans out
they're holding hands into the table
yeah the end
a story of toxic relationships are
beautiful
yeah i remember in the beginning of the
film
he ditched that girl yeah
he [ __ ] left her hanging dry because
he didn't want to be set up by his
[ __ ] aunt
right and it turned out to be that girl
so they were already kind of destined to
meet each other it was her
all along yeah it was her all along
which is kind of nuts and i was like man
what a good way
to tie up this rom-com it was really
good like this that was like
there's only a few rom-coms that i
really like that's one and then 500 days
of summer
right is another one that i really liked
because it was very representative of
like
how um when we're in a relationship we
don't like to see
all the fallacies and the disasters when
you're heartbroken you can only remember
the best parts
because you're so desperately wanting to
be with this person right but when you
take a step back and you realize all the
reasons why you guys
broke up there's there's a reason why
this happened that's why i like 500
it was so relatable right and that 500
days of summer too was really quirky
i've never seen it you should watch it
it's really quirky too there's like
these moments where they break up in the
song and dance it's odd
zoe deschanel and jjl i believe is that
it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah you like it
that's like one of the very few rom-coms
that i really really like yeah i'm not
big into rom-coms but this movie
does it for me um like love actually i
get it like i i appreciate its factor
um but i feel like it feels the same um
because rom-coms are
constantly playing with this thing with
fate
um a lot of wrong comes kind of feel
like a
crash without the racism
but um this one plays it out really well
where it's like it's coincidental but
then if it is
that unbelievable just make it [ __ ]
funny
yeah and it did it really well yeah uh
this was i i felt heavy about it because
like
about my shitty past relationships but
it also helps me
laugh at the pain that i went through
yeah
kidding punched in the face they did
it's weird too because if i read this
script
i would think that it would be it
wouldn't do well because of how all over
the place it is
in when you just read it on paper right
you know but the way it kind of plays
out it's nothing how you would have ever
expected right
right it's like how i feel about uh
scott pilgrim saves the universe right
if you're right yeah right so yeah if i
would have seen that
on paper i'm like no this is the dumbest
thing ever
but scott pilgrim is one of my favorite
films of
all time i [ __ ] love that i always
watch it once a year yeah
that is one of my fav and in likes of
scott pilgrim i actually wrote a korean
drama series
based on how on edgar wright's writing
right and
a little bit of how my sassy girl is
right it's it's those two are some of my
two top favorite films
like they they kind of mix in this weird
like
reality non-reality thing yeah yeah
where you play to the creativity of your
imagination
yes you make it meta um your imagination
is part of the edit
your imagination is part of the music
right like we're
like when you say 500 days of summer
like yeah your imagination comes to
life in this crazy exaggerated way and
then you
come back down earth yeah like i i love
those things too because we live that
life being
raised by television right in our
daydreams just
also compliant those things that are
very
unreal it's it's not represented in how
we do things but it's how we feel
we feel it's a pure representation it's
a physical representation of our
emotions yeah right so when you see
people breaking the song and dancing
it's ridiculous
that's how it feels let me tell you this
i just remembered something and it's a
little embarrassing but i'm gonna say it
anyways
the very first girlfriend that i got
together i i chased this girl for a
while and i kind of like had my feelings
at bay because all my friends liked her
too so i was like
whatever yeah eventually i said [ __ ] it
i'm leaving the school anyways i'm just
gonna go ahead and uh put myself out
there and let's see if we're gonna date
so finally she says yes right
and i was shocked and she said yeah like
let's i want to be with you
tell you something doug she lived like
maybe like a
15 minute walk away from my house bro i
was doing cartwheels and
jumps and flips running all the way back
home
yeah i'm talking about the most
embarrassing thing ever dude like i'm
screaming
like so so when i saw that whole thing
you know when he's like breaking into
song and dance i'm like i
actually did that yeah as an eight as a
[ __ ] 17 year old kid
it's a beautiful day that's exactly what
it was like
so when i see that i'm like that's how
people feel on the inside you know it's
like when somebody says like uh
it's very uh like kind of willy wonka
issue i mean like
i have butterflies in my stomach you see
butterflies pop out of your mouth right
um
amelie right yeah almost yeah like that
feeling
it's you can call this the korean amelie
the korean
edgar right like it's so much so much of
that that
what you love about film packed into
this
i think you'll find it here that's why
we love it such a great film
but also by the way with this other you
know
every girl like that i've dated have
risen has resented me
but i've also also like you know had a
cordial like kind of
friendship after two because even this
girl too i talked about
you know my sassy girl where we broke up
i saw her
a couple months ago oh really she was
visiting l.a
she had dinner and she's doing fine
she's great
we're grown up you know and it's just
like you look back like yeah we were
crazy kids
yeah you know she's a little more crazy
though yeah yeah
i mean you know her talking somebody in
the face
you know but yeah um i was not very nice
to her when i met her too yeah
like we'll tell we'll talk about that
another time
but yeah um i mean i mean in saying that
so much of craziness happens in this
movie right
and then they still do the adult things
of having to break up because they need
to be apart because they have to
yeah even me and this girl like i had to
[ __ ]
end this [ __ ] with her and when it was
getting bad when it was just getting too
toxic
because this is a movie about toxic
relationships and they do the right
thing they split when like
they don't they split they grow up they
grow up and then you know what fate
brought them together
and me and this girl we split i had a
[ __ ] ghost her i had to leave her
out like it was rough it was hard
and then i just saw her again for the
first time in like six years
and you know what i'm just grown up yeah
there's peace behind it and like
none of those weird feelings in the past
or whatever doesn't come by we're in the
future now
yeah we are here in the present and you
know
who she is today doesn't is you're a
really good person like once i
leave somebody you're you're deleted but
i never want to see you again though but
i also have my moment where
look i look like this right now i look
homeless
and crazy right now because i actually
got dumped last september
yeah another girl and so i haven't been
taking care of my face
but we agreed to call each other after a
month
and i haven't been able to now look
they gave each other two years this girl
gave me a month to get better it's like
ah that's not how it works like it's
very short yeah and so it's already
[ __ ] february
yeah so i'm kind of like trying to get
my [ __ ] together
still i guess and that's where i was
kind of anxious about watching this
movie
where it was like
i'm going to yeah
have to grow up and get my [ __ ] together
to have to really
talk to this person if i wanted this
this
type of person again in my life right
just like honey did
like there's so like we do everything
because this girl is perfect for me but
we don't do anything to be
perfect for that the girl yeah right put
us in that place well you know what's
interesting like when i
when mary and i first started going out
um
you know she did this whole thing where
i think uh she wanted to keep her
options
open right and i think for her she'd
like to play a lot of games you know
in such the korean girl fashion yes you
know
and so she you know she would always say
these things when we first started going
out she goes
yeah well there's this other guy that
i'm really interested in too because we
were kind of just dating openly
right um and at the time i was kind of
fooling around
with one of your friends yeah
so um she
kept on mentioning this other dude right
yeah she met through some [ __ ] dating
app right
and i already told her explicitly at
this point like i was i was like
this girl was just fun right and i was
like okay listen like i like you like
we're straight forward
like i really really like you you know
and but she kept on mentioning this
other dude so i literally told her i was
like you know what i'm done
i was like good luck and she was like
what do you mean i'm like yo like listen
i think you have something really
confused like
i don't know you you don't know me i
don't owe you anything you don't owe me
anything
and what i said to her verbatim was you
have something very twisted right now
you you think that i'm trying to figure
out if i'm good for you i'm trying to
figure out if you're good for me
ooh right so you go ahead and figure out
what you're going to do i told you how i
feel
and when you're when you when you're
done you let me know and i hung up the
phone
after i hung up the phone i was like
she's going to leave me
why did you say this i was like oh god
you're so stupid
i was so mad at myself i'm like who the
[ __ ] do you think you are
the last time you did this your girl
ghosted you and you [ __ ] cried at her
ankles you
dumbass you know but it turned out it
worked it worked
this time right um in the same way
because this past girl gave me
so much trauma with how crazy she was
when i started dating someone else i
started behaving this way
because of my trauma from this other
girl
and then when she called me out like why
are you being like this and i would say
oh this last girl
and she was like stop i'm not that girl
obviously yeah it's like i'm not that
person not everybody no one's that
person she's her she's like
i'm me and come get to know me i'm
eunice kim
her name is jay how can we get any
better than that
right okay well that wraps up this
episode oh that's too [ __ ] funny dude
oh man well that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast i hope you
liked
this review of number one korean culture
and also this film uh you guys have been
enjoying this
uh i'll let you up clearly i'm gonna let
you guys know on instagram um
to watch this film beforehand before you
watch this review because it's very
telling and it'll help you guys
understand what this film's about let me
know if you guys have watched this agree
or disagree you can find ed at ed parkvp
on instagram and you remember uh every
genius brain every thursday and sundays
and we'll see you all next time
peace peace